some very serious accusations in the
sunday times they have an interview with
the conservative mp nusrat ghani in
which she says that when she was sacked
as a minister from the department for
transport in february 2020 she was told
by government whip that the reason she
was sacked was because
some people
were
uncomfortable with her muslim women
minister status and that there were
concerns that she wasn't loyal to the
party and didn't do enough to defend the
conservative party against allegations
of islamophobia so very very serious
accusations
and in a pretty rare intervention the
chief whip
the boss of the whips and the government
enforcers in westminster mark spencer
has tweeted um this evening you don't
usually hear from chief whip so it is
quite a rare thing
to say that he was the person that nus
ghani is referring to these are the
tweets that he sent out he said to
ensure other whips are not drawn into
this matter i'm identifying myself as
the person nuzrat ghani mp has made
claims about this evening these
accusations are completely false and i
consider them to be defamatory i have
never used those words attributed to me
it is disappointed that when this issue
was raised before miss ghani she
declined to refer the mata to the
conservative party for a formal
investigation now in that interview with
the sunday times nuzghani says that the
reason why she didn't bring this up
sooner was because at the time
she was told that she would be
ostracized by colleagues if she brought
it up and that her career and her
reputation would be destroyed we have
heard from other government ministers
really mps from across the political
spectrum the education secretary nadim
zahawi tweeted uh saying that there
needed to be a proper investigation
there was no place for racism or
islamophobia tom tugenhart a senior mp
and conservative committee chair also
said there should be an inquiry as has
the former chief which mark harper and
also the labour party calling for an
investigation as well william rag who of
course is meeting the police to discuss
intimidation and blackmail accusations
next week
also said that he was appalled
and that the party needed to do better
now nus ghani was
the first
female woman muslim minister to speak
from the dispatch box she was applauded
and cheered when that
happened she says though that this
experience has left her feeling
powerless so more serious accusations
landing at the government's door as we
move into what's likely to be quite a
difficult week for the prime minister